the press conference we understand well
it's going to start imminently it's
going to start scheduled for 12 o'clock
in the building behind me um port collis
house we expect them to come in any
moment now nazanin is going to be
uh accompanied by her husband richard a
man who we've all come to know so well
over the years due to his tireless
relentless campaigning to secure his
wife's release from iran over the last
six years they're also going to be
accompanied by tulip sadiq
the the
family's local mp in north london
um who uh nazney actually met for the
first time face to face uh yesterday uh
and it was an encounter chili's
described as being quite weird because
um the pair actually have come to known
each other and come to know each other
very well
over the last six years because of all
the phone conversations they've been
having um whilst nazaneen was in prison
but despite that they've never actually
met in person of course until yesterday
so julia sadiq said it was tearful and
emotional and i think there will be a
lot of emotion uh on display in this
press conference from everyone because
naznen's story is one that all of us
have become quite invested in over the
last few years politicians journalists
members the members of the public and
it's going to be quite a moment isn't it
seeing her on british soil in front of
the cameras here
uh speaking about her experience what
it's been like over the last six years
there are so many questions
people will want to ask what was her
treatment like what were the conditions
like what kept her going
all these years um what kept the family
going um richard radcliffe of course
went on hunger strike
outside the foreign office at the end of
last year nazanin was on hunger strike
whilst in prison a few years ago at one
point
there have been so many ups and downs
over the last few years when they
thought she might be released only to
have those hopes dashed what was it like
not seeing her daughter grow up what's
it like now
trying to readjust and being together
once again
so many questions i don't think we're
going to get all of the answers but it
is going to be quite a moment to witness
quite surreal i think
nazanin uh in the last few days has been
spending time with her family in north
london where they live she was released
um after the government paid this
long-standing uh debt of 400 million
pounds to iran that dates back to the
1970s and there's still an intense
debate around
why this uh why her release was not
secured sooner if the government was
going to ultimately end up paying that
debt anyway i don't think they'll be
you know today is obviously about the
personal side of things and what naznen
has to say about her her own experience
but i think
there will be some questions
on in that vein
today because the fourth person at this
press conference is is roxanne tabaz who
is the daughter
of
morad tabaz who is a british american 66
year old conservationist who is still
being held in tehran he was released
from prison when
nazanin was released
earlier this week he
was is held has been held since january
2018 on spying charges which he denies
um
but whilst he was released from prison
he was then sent back to prison after
nazanin arrived back in the uk
and um and then in the last few days
he's also been released again and is now
we understand in a hotel in tehran now
the foreign office has said it is still
putting
pressure on the iranian authorities
either we're fading you out i'm afraid
rather unceremoniously uh as they come
in to the press conference uh nazis gary
radcliffe and her husband gabriella is
gonna the daughter's gonna be sitting
down in the audience by the looks of it
um but richard radcliffe and also uh
tulip siddiki helical mp and as we were
saying roxanne tabas also at that table
let's listen
in and then we'll sit in silence
um
good afternoon
thank you very much for being here today
for those of you i haven't met i'm tulip
sadiq and the mp for hampstead and
kilburn or as i'm commonly known now the
nazanin mp
that's what i've come to be nonan i
wanted to say thank you first of all to
the speaker's office for hosting this
press conference and for
welcoming us to parliament earlier on
and welcoming nazanin richard and
gabriella to parliament and hosting us
in his room
i know that a lot of people have to be
thanked for this campaign because it
took six long years to bring nazanin
back and i think nazney and richard will
both thank lots of people but i just
wanted to take a minute if that's okay
to pay tribute to my constituents
my constituents here today are an
ordinary family who were thrust into
extraordinary circumstances and they
rose to the challenge
richard is known for his relentless
campaigning
nazine is known for her immense strength
in the face of huge adversity and little
gabriella who's sitting in the front is
known to be a brave soul it was a family
who never lost hope and that's why i'm
so pleased to welcome there to their
welcome them to their first press
conference
the reason why they're here
is because the foreign office and the
fcdo officials worked really hard to
bring them back
and i thank them for that but i also
want to say
that i owe it to nazanin to ask
questions about why it took so long to
bring nasaline back
and why the debt wasn't paid for so long
which we know was key to releasing
nazanin so i've written to tom
tuggenhead the chair of the foreign
affairs select committee to ask for a
review
into what happened in nazanin's case
the two things i'll be asking the
foreign affairs select committee to look
at is first of all an incident that took
place in 2013
when three iranian officials came to
heathrow to negotiate the repayment of
the historic debt that we owe iran or
old iran has now been paid they were
arrested at heathrow airport and then
detained in a uk detention center
i spoke to jack straw yesterday who said
he never got to the bottom of why that
happened and jack straw said he firmly
believes that saga contributed to
important people in the iranian regime
wanting to take matters into their own
hands and make sure there was more
direct action for the repayment of the
debt
the second thing i'll be asking the
foreign affairs select committee to look
at if they accept the inquiry is to look
at why there was a deal made last year
which then fell through and the money
wasn't paid either and i want to know
why the deal fell through why it took so
long to pay the debt and i also want to
look at the wider issue of taking
hostages which iran has done
and speaking on the topic of taking
hostages nazneen has today asked roxanne
tavaz to be on the panel with us she's
the daughter of murad tabas who is still
detained in iran
murad tabaz his last known address in
the uk was in my constituency but
roxanne is felicity bukhan's mp felicity
buchan is roxanne's mp and felicity is
here today so thank you very much
felicity for joining us at short notice
and that leaves me to say please wear a
face covering if you're able to and
you're not speaking most people aren't
but i have been asked to stay in norway
no but if you're speaking it's okay
richard will forgive you this one and
and in terms of the panel i'm going to
ask richard to speak and then going to
ask nazanin to speak and then i'm going
to ask roxanne to speak we will then
take questions after that when you are
asking a question i'd be really grateful
if you could stand up and ask a question
and there will be a roving mic that will
come to you
could i just finish by saying gently
that nazine has just come out of six
years of immense trauma if you have very
political questions
please direct them to the politician on
the panel or to richard
thank you
so
i will now hand over to richard
thank you everyone um and obviously you
don't really want to hear from me
because you've heard from me plenty um
these past six years and it's it's nice
to be retiring um in that sense it's
been a a long struggle
um it's
yeah
i'm immensely immensely pleased and
proud of my wife
um proud to have a home and proud that
we start a new chapter and and you know
get to be a normal family again um
two things i wanted to say really one
one
there are lots of thank yous
um to say a bit like a you know
like groomed speech at a wedding um
so
thank you
everyone
i
you
know
you know the foreign secretary did
promise to get nursing home
a groomed speech at a wedding um
so
thank you to
um
everyone in parliament um i i
you know when i actually thank you for
the government first um you know the
foreign secretary did promise to get
nursing home and she did um and that's
been a long struggle um lots of foreign
office staff
i've been working behind the scenes and
we haven't always agreed i've been
plenty rude enough in public at points
about them
um
but we had a lovely three days
with them
after leslie came home
very nurturing
very caring
very kind people
and
they got home
so it is for us
over
a new chapter
a process of healing and recovery and
and going back to normal um and we'd be
just you know in the speaker's office
um you know well six years ago
we wouldn't have been treated with a
sort of grandeur and and reception that
that is here and it
it is a great honor um
i
am really grateful to tulip
um to all of the mps who have battled
for nazarene um we were saying one of
the things that was really striking on
wednesday at the debate in parliament
when leslie was on the plane
was actually on all sides
people were pleased
people recognised our injustice people
battled it pushed the government to be
honest keep the oven honest and
um i'm hugely grateful for all of that
care and support
um
that came
because lots of people in the media
kept nothing in the light
in different ways and different times
and kept our family story in the night
and could see the injustice and it came
because
lots of
people up and down the country
followed our story and cared
um
i think you know with campaigning um a
lot of people actually sent me that
there's a poem
by a man called um
constantine simeonov
um called
about waiting a waitress a lot of people
sent me just recently i haven't i
confess i haven't i hadn't seen it
before but
you know it feels like i've spent six
years
conspicuously waiting um
and and lots
and lots of people have waited with us
um and that waiting has kept her safe
and here we are um so thank you to
everyone who has been part of bringing
leslie home and for making us whole
again
um
the other thing to say is before i hand
over nothing of course
it is baby steps
baby steps for us as a family um on the
journey back to normal um
and and i have promised me um you know
that any questions i'll answer and
doesn't have to
um
there is a
lovely reunion
um i am
super proud
of her strength and her survival
and
her grace
um
i'm so pleased she's back home with me
that she came home to us um
we're still negotiating with her daddy's
allowed in the same bed as as gabriella
and leslie
and
we'll get there um
but
yeah it's
it's you know i think we'll we'll do
this and then we will disappear off and
heal a bit
um
and uh yeah i do feel um honored that
we've got
roxanne here today as their family's
journey continues
um
but
yeah i i this is my retirement day and
and i'm thankful that has come so thank
you
thank you very much richard and that
leaves me to ask and as aline zagari
radcliffe to speak
um
i would like to begin
by saying that i am
very grateful
to whoever has been involved in getting
us home from politicians media members
whoever has been
trying very hard to get our voices heard
i'm grateful i also want to begin with
thanking i mean i will not be able to
thank everybody but i want to kind of
categorize my family in the uk who have
been really really supportive my family
in iran who wanted to be speaking up but
the situation in iran is very difficult
you will be under so much pressure that
you will not be able to speaking up for
your own right so they were very much
both scared to talk about it but at the
same time
and
willing to do that but thankfully we had
my amazing wonderful
um husband to to do the job while you
know we were um kind of worryingly uh
and impatiently waiting around to see
what's going to happen next
i want to thank all my um
friends as well in iran who supported me
over the past two years and i was under
house arrests
and when i came out of the attack to
entertain me and keep me upbeat
i also want to thank all the medical
team in iran who have been looking after
me it was an amazing experience to see
people who knew me
through media just to be you know
looking after me when i was under house
arrest and when i came out of it just to
give me medical support and you know
advice
i would like to thank
the members of um
prisoners of the family members of
prisoners in iran who i happen to be
very very close
with
just like um
rossan's
parents and family
who have been
really supporting me all along this
journey
i want to thank my amazing lawyer in
iran
he has been accompanying me to the court
and fearlessly fighting for my release
there is very little lawyers in iran can
do regard
with regards to human rights but i think
he has been just amazing throughout that
journey and
the least but not last my amazing
husband who
has been
tirelessly campaigning for me so thank
you so much and my daughter for being
very very patient with mommy to be
coming home so i am so grateful
i also want to mention one thing and
that is
i believe that the meaning of freedom is
never going to be complete until such
time that
all of us who are unjustly um you know
detained in iran are reunited with our
families to begin with murads but also
the other dual nationals you know
members of the um
like religious groups or prisoners of
conscience who are i mean we do realize
that if i have been in prison for six
years there are so many other people we
don't know their names who have been you
know suffering in prison in iran so i i
think
the justice in iran does not
have any meaning because in worst case
scenario you are you know being given
um
the the unfair trial if you're lucky
then you'll be picked up by
by kind of semi-fair judge but in most
cases you're not being lucky um
the journey back home was tough i grant
what richard said to thank the
uh
foreign secretary i have i do not really
agree with him on that level uh i'm
going to tell you that because i have
seen five foreign secretaries changed
over the course of six years that is
unprecedented given the politics of the
uk i love you richard respect whatever
you believe but i was told many many
times that oh
we're going to get you home that never
happened so there was a time that i felt
like you know what i'm like no i'm not
even going to trust you because i've
been told many many times that i'm going
to be taken home but that never happened
i mean how many foreign secretaries does
it take for someone to come out five
it should have been one of them
eventually so
now here we are what's happened now
should have happened six years ago uh i
think we all know
this is i'm assuming this is going to be
public knowledge how i came home
i'm not gonna mention i don't know the
details but what took me home now
on the very same day 17th of march 2022
then it's a very same day that i left
london
17th of march 2016 to go on a two-week
holiday and i never returned
on the flight that i was coming back
home with but i think it should have
happened exactly six years ago i
shouldn't have been in prison for six
years
um
and um
and yeah i think
i think
we have we have gone through a lot it
has been a tough journey
um
the coming back was also very tough
uh
so you you do realize that you know
coming back to a daughter who is nearly
eight
i left her when she was not even two
there was a whole lot to catch up with
richard um
and gabrielle and getting to know them
better
so i would appreciate
you know the privacy
and um
yeah and thank you very very much i i
think i should really thank
uh the media members because that is how
the world happened to know my story so i
am grateful for that
thank you
and could i now ask roxanne to ask to
speak and tell her story about her
father murat sabas
okay uh firstly i'd like to thank the
ratford family for giving me the
platform to share our story uh and i
think it goes without saying that we're
genuinely pleased for both of you for
your extended family and we hope to
share a similar experience in the very
near future
my name is roxyanis as tulip said i'm
moraden vira tovaz's eldest daughter
it's been over four years now since my
father was detained and my mother was
put on a travel ban within iran
as you can imagine my siblings and i are
desperate to be reunited with our
parents and therefore i'm here today to
ask the question of why my father as the
only uk born national has been abandoned
and left behind there
my father was removed from him his salad
avein prison yesterday but we've only
just found out before we started
this afternoon that he's been returned
to the prison
contrary to the public statements that
have been made he's not been reunited
with his family and he certainly has not
been given a furlough
as was part of the deal that was
presented to us
from the outset we were always assured
by the fcdo that my father would be
included in any deal that was made to
release all of the hostages so we're
truly devastated knowing now that this
was not the case
further to our dismay we learned that
he'd been left behind through the media
last week
to prime minister johnson and foreign
secretary truss we beg you to please
stand by your word and bring back both
of my my parents my father and my mother
thank you
thanks very much and i'm gonna take
questions from the floor now if you
wouldn't mind standing up a mic will
come to you even if i know you uh and
everyone on this panel might not know
you so please say your name and which
organization you're from yes could i
take indications please
um
yeah there's a mic um i'm actually quite
loud so
we know
okay
there is a mic behind you there you go
thank you thank you so much and um
it's just it's it's wonderful it's
wonderful to see you home so i just want
to start saying that
but it was a long six years
it was six years where you were
apart from richard
and your daughter who was buttered baby
and then a toddler
the government repeatedly refused to
acknowledge the link
between your imprisonment
and that debt which has now been paid
and while you must be absolutely
delighted
to be home
i guess my question is do you feel
really angry with the government too
that it took
too long and also what's your message to
political prisoners
that are still left behind thanks dad
thank you
um
i think the answer is clear i
cannot be um happier a lot
happier than this that i'm here but also
like i said this should have happened
six years ago so i think that answers
your question
that uh
i i always felt like i am holding this
black hole in my heart
all these years
but i'm just going to leave that black
black hole in my heart i'm going to
leave that black hole on the plane when
the plane lands i'm not going to live
for the rest of my life with a grudge
over the past six years it has been
cruel what happened to me
um
but i think i will
i do not want to
um
kind of
this moment is so glorious for me so i i
don't i don't want to and it's kind of
early days that i have come back so i
think it's a bit early to think that
you know
to to hold on to that garage but
it should have happened six years ago i
mean it took a long very very long time
for the politicians to study that um
i was the lucky one who regard regarding
your the second part of your question i
was the lucky one who
got to be recognized internationally
even the campaign which was running but
there are so many other people in prison
that you don't know their names and they
have been imprisoned for
longer years that i have been
um
so i think
regarding the um every person has got
the right to be free and freedom is
something which has to be given to
people
and i think the world should unite
together to make sure that there is no
one
held
either hostage or in prison for
something they haven't done
thanks sesame and i might do row by row
it might be slightly easier as i'll come
to you next thank you
mike please
carl dimmon from itv news
first of all i hope you understand just
how delighted everyone in this country
is to see you back our hearts have gone
up to your family all the way through
this and it's wonderful to see you
sitting here thank you
perhaps you could just tell us how much
you were aware of when you were
being held of what was going on
in the outside world and the efforts to
get you out and perhaps also the
setbacks you talked about
six five foreign secretaries over six
years of course one of the foreign
secretaries who do that was your case
was boris johnson and he said sitting in
one of these rooms that you were out
there teaching journalists which you
weren't
did you hear about that and what did the
iranians tell you about what it did to
europe
how did you feel it affected what
happened to you i did not have much
information about the arts abroad being
in prison
prison is a very secluded space you only
have got access to state media and then
a couple of newspapers and there were
not much happening and we had like
visits every every week but then i would
have loved to spend the time with her so
long as she was in iran than talking
about politics if i'm honest so i didn't
know what was going on uh if only
something was coming up in the news and
i would have known otherwise no
and i think there is a lot to know now
that i've come back
so we will have so many nights of
chatting about stories
perhaps at the moment the
necessity of talking about them is less
than what it used to be at the time but
i think there were times that i realized
that
i'm in prison i've got 40 minutes to see
my baby and have a have a story with her
or like you know do something we used to
have lots of stuff in the wizard room
like coloring and singing and things
like that and i was not going to miss
that opportunity so i did not spend time
following the politics behind my story
and i thought you know what i am
powerless in prison i will
see
what will happen and that was how i took
it because
that was like a like a way for me to
survive because i couldn't
when you accept that you don't have uh
you know the
uh you do not have the um the means to
get to know what is happening outside
then you're gonna have to come to terms
with that and that's what i did so the
answer is no thank you yes
hi martin street from itv news london at
nazarene three years ago
richard and gabriella were handing in a
mother's day car to attend downing
street to try and get your freedom
looking forward to this sunday first
mother's day for six years you get to
spend it together what are you gonna do
and how special a moment is that gonna
be i didn't know that sunday's mother's
day
it's like i don't see
anything
the only thing i knew was yesterday was
no ruse
uh was the persian new year
and
the only thing that i did was sitting we
just quickly put
the
table together and with the people that
we were we were were with them we just
sat down and i just talked to my family
and i just enjoyed the moment so
we'll see how it goes on sunday yeah
awesome
they come to you please i agree at the
moment i'll do row
amazing to see you here um can i ask how
you felt as you walked down the steps of
that plane at bryson orton
is it too early to say what the future
now holds is there anything you want to
say about the difficult
times you spent in jail and
most importantly how are you
it's very early to
to think what is going to happen next
that moment was precious
i have been waiting for that moment for
such a long time and i was overwhelmed
specifically to get to know
gabriella
and richard after such a long time it
was a very very emotional moment
um but uh but i don't know we will see
what what happens in the future i think
it's too early for me to to think about
that i'm just enjoying the moment
thank you
continue next year um would you mind
hanging from michael please thank you
natasha phillips keihan live welcome
home
no balak roxanna i'm really sorry to
hear about your father's case um my
question is either for tulip or richard
once you receive a response from tom
tuggenhut um will you be considering a
judicial review
should i take that one
no probably the short answer um
you know i i
obviously at points we've been angry um
and and you know a lot of us will know
that
um we said it fairly bluntly i mean
behind closed doors um when we were in
in seclusion um we were talking about
like it is useful to to review what
happened and what we can learn from it
um i think the suggestion of a foreign
affairs committee review inquiry is a
really good one i think um there are
specific issues in our case but there's
a wider issue about
how the government deals with hostage
taking how it can do it better it's not
easy
the foreign office has a challenging job
iran is trixie and you know everything
that's happened
to roxanne's dad in the past 48 hours
demonstrates that
um
i think it would be really valuable
for parliament to to take up that
challenge and to talk it through um
i think that's best done yeah through
parliament rather than sort of angry
lawyers and and you know everyone having
to sort of cover themselves um
but but i mean as i said it's early days
i i i don't think i mean i yeah i feel i
am retiring from campaigning rather than
going into a um let's lobby the foreign
affairs committee um kind of a stage but
um i think i think it's i think there's
an important point there
just leaving it to me richard i see
could you pass mike on thank you do you
want to
yes please um my name's patrick from the
guardian i just wanted to know whether
you
this might be black hole territory you
don't want to talk about which i
understand but um could you describe
what solitary confinement
is like what effect it had
uh i would not be comfortable answering
your question i'm sorry patrick
can i then ask you another
question on the on the issue of the debt
um
is that what you felt held back your
release and failure to pay the debt and
then why do you think it wasn't paid
so it's one question i don't know but i
was told early on that they there is
something they want after breaks and
they're not gonna let me go until such
time that they get that and they were
correct about it
so i didn't know the details at the time
but i think it was the
the week two or week three that i was
arrested like six years ago that they
told me we have we want something off
the bridge we will not let you go until
such time that we get it
and they did keep their promise
that's right
thank you thank you
hi nazinee that's catherine phil from
the times um it's amazing to see you
it's quite overwhelming actually
um and you seem so well i think it's um
easy to forget some of the horrible
cruelty that you've been subjected to
and i wanted to ask you about i know
you've had some advice from terry waite
about how to emerge from this
trauma that you've been through and i
just wondered if if there was any of his
advice that you could tell us that
you've um drawn some comfort from
um i
uh it's very difficult for me to talk
about what i've gone through so i would
rather not answer that question and i
think this moment is just
coming back home
and just enjoying
it will always haunt me there is no
other way around it it will be with me
i mean terry weight is a good example it
is never going to leave you alone but i
think at the moment i would rather
just focus on the moment of coming back
home
that's absolutely fine can i just then
ask you have you tidied the flat yeah
i don't know
we haven't gone
brace yourself thank you is there anyone
in the third row yeah could i come to
you please
yeah sorry
so and then we'll come to this bit hi
nazine just wanted to say welcome home
we're just so pleased to have you here
my name is lynn rusk i just wanted to
ask i suppose was there a specific
memory of home of your daughter richard
what was it do you think that really
helped you survive through this time
what is it that you're most excited to
be back for
um my memory faded as
the time went by but the most
visible memory was
gabriella playing and richard getting me
a cup of um penalty at the time because
i was breastfeeding so i was having um
but that was that was the most vivid
memory that i that i would have but then
it then again faded gradually so i had
very vague memory of that we still
haven't picked up because we haven't
been to the flat so we're looking
forward to that
thank you yeah
stephen council from the new york times
uh nazarene um i just wonder did you
always manage to keep your your faith
and your confidence that you would be
released and if so how did you manage to
keep that straight and to richard please
um
i think right at the beginning of this
you were encouraged to keep very quiet
and not to rock the boat and to sort of
keep your mouth shut
do you think that if you'd
uh done so we would now have the result
that we we have and what would be your
um advice to other people in um
regrettably similar situations
if you wanted to come to you first yeah
it's a good question like i think and
it's a question that all as families we
all struggle with um
six years on
i don't think i know what the best
solution is if i'm honest
i think
it felt right i mean we waited for a
month actually we didn't go public day
one um and then we went loud and we went
consistently loud and and i always used
to
beat myself up as to what we could do to
to you know get it over the line what
what was gonna you know it wasn't just
simple outrage there was there was more
going on and and
our story with that story you never know
what you don't know
um
i think my
advice to any family
is is to follow your gut
and to be authentic about it
my gut told me
that this was
outrageous
and crazy and there must be something
else going on
and to speak out about it um it didn't
tell me on day one day one i was
bewildered
um but but once i did i did and it was
tough for nasa's father
but his gut told him
not to stir up a hornet's nest um and
and he didn't feel that it was
particularly sensible of his son-in-law
to stare at her um well it's not like we
got around six weeks
we got around six years um i am
eternally grateful
to everyone involved in getting around
some of whom are in this room
um
you know because our life can start
again
there were bumps along the way it might
have happened differently it happened
this way for us
i hope it happens soon for roxanne's dad
thank you could i go to yes yes
thank you
this is a question i'm asking richard
regarding this as you know there are
other dual nationals detained in iran
like morale
will you really want to retire from
campaigning and speaking out for others
or are you going to carry on campaigning
for them
so
i mean
the short answer is nazney wants to come
home to a husband and to normal life um
not a professional campaigner um
and i think i mean i i yeah it's every
family
battles in their own way but we all we
all are part of a club that no one wants
to belong to
um and we do all care for each other and
and behind the scenes all will help each
other into playing perfectly
i mean they'd like all things in life um
and i think
you know for me
we'll see what happens if there is sort
of an inquiry if there is various things
we were in the middle of with
campaigning that
we know we might finish off and carry on
things like magnitsky sanctions um that
are a collective effort that that will
probably calm down a bit our involvement
but it won't disappear
um
but no my my job is is is to you know
recover um and for us to be a normal
family again it's it's not to be sitting
in front of you guys for um you know
years to come thank you
um could i go to the lady yeah please
i'll come by it's tessa
it's wonderful to see home and wonderful
to see richard with such a big smile on
his face as well because we've all seen
him in grumpy different circumstances um
i wonder if i could ask you did you know
that richard had it in him to
campaign
and to be so
unswervingly dedicated and did you learn
much about yourself
while you're away too and second
question there's a wonderful photograph
of you when you get home and you're
holding gabriella and your head is on
richard's shoulder and i want if you
could tell me how you felt when that
photo was taken
it is it is um surreal
to come back and to be
holding my husband and my
baby
and who's not baby anymore but also i
think um
i'm not going to answer the first part
of your question
but the second part of your question is
i did go through a journey to
get to know myself a lot better
to get to know my strengths and
my faith more than anything else um so
it was um a journey with a huge huge
huge price
but i think it is something that not
many people in the world would
experience
so um looking back
we paid a huge price for it but at the
end of the day we it made us a lot
closer we made so many good friends and
got to know families of the
uh ex-prisoners or prisoners or um and
this woman in prison so i think it made
us a lot closer to each other and a lot
stronger together
um but he paid a massive price for it
thank you i'm sorry we're really short
of time so if you could only ask one
question i'd be really grateful yes
um hello david bond from the evening
standard um can i ask were there was
there a moment or were there moments
where you thought you were about to be
released and you might be able to come
home
that were then dashed and how did that
feel
yeah there were many moments that i felt
like that um
i felt
like i was left behind i assume this is
exactly what morad is feeling at the
moment that you know
two of us came home he was left behind
so i fully understand what he's going
through at the moment because it is
disappointing
um
it kind of
um it puts you in a situation that you
you can easily lose faith in everything
um
i have been through that i think twice
over the past maybe three times over the
past six years and that is why i think
what we should be doing for morale
is something that shouldn't have
happened to him he should have been on
the same flight with his chemical and it
should happen to this to the other dual
nationals so i think it is frustrating
um
it is disappointing
but then
in my opinion it was my face that made
me go through it
yes thank you
uh henry bodkin from the telegraph a
question for roxanne
um do you have any idea uh from the
government whether they have any
bargaining chips uh in respect of
getting your dad home
um
are you hearing anything from them is
there anything
practically that you would urge them to
do to help speed up the process and and
are you frustrated perhaps that your
dad's release wasn't linked to the
payment of the debt uh there was an
opportunity there thank you
um i've i haven't been appraised of the
situation in terms of what's being
negotiated at this time we were advised
that he would be on an indefinite photo
which turned out to not be the case
and we also were advised that my mom's
travel ban would have been lifted as
well which is also still not the case
i i'm not a politician so sadly i can't
advise anyone in the government what
they can offer and negotiate but we just
urge them to to bring them back home
they've been there a very long time
could you would you mind passing them
out to rosemont please yeah thank you
thank you for the sunday times um
congratulations it's wonderful to see
you congratulations richard
i just wanted to know the last few days
before you came home when did you feel
secure in the knowledge you were coming
back and richard when was that feeling
for you as well
only when i got on the plane
not before
because there has been so many games in
the past that i did not feel like i
should really let myself believe the
moment
um and i think it was just an element
that the the airplane
the stairs went up and it and it took
off that i realized that the moment is
real
yeah it seemed to me i think there were
a lot of games that happened that we
didn't air and perhaps won't ever want
to wear but um you know there's a lot of
uncertainty about what's going to happen
in in in the last stages and our
experience and many other hostages as
well
um you know we've had four stones before
we clearly weren't close way it felt
like it in the last few days was getting
closer
but but probably there was always a gap
between what i thought was going to
happen and the foreign officers saying
listen it's moving it's moving and i you
know until until it's happened it hasn't
um well now it has um and it's a lovely
feeling
hi naznan massive welcome home it's
great to see you um just a quick one how
was your first weekend of freedom is
gabriella getting used to having mummy
home
and and i wondered also how your mom and
dad were back in iran um and if you've
ever felt in a million years perhaps
you'd be able to travel back there and
see them again um
well she has been
upgrading mommy to be with her and
downgrading sadly daddy a little bit
um
you know and rightly so
making up for the past um
we i haven't seen gabriella for the past
two and a half years because she wasn't
around with my parents
and she left iran in october 20 um
2019.
so lots of catching up it was lovely to
you know to get to hold her to braid her
hair and to brush her hair that was the
moment that i really really missed um my
parents were
uh
relieved i must admit that i felt like
my mom would be very very upset she was
not she was so happy that this whole
thing
is over the only thing which was um kind
of bothering my mom and that was like
there was my presence in the flat
because i was living with them for the
past two years and i think it was my
absence which was bothering them more
than anything else but they were very
very much relieved that um
i'm back
regarding the
travel traveling back to iran
yeah you know my opinion
it took me six years to come back i
think i will be very very cautious about
um is there did you okay so could i have
could you hand the mic please the
gentleman behind yeah you've got mike
yeah thank you uh jonathan rockman from
channel 4 uh welcome and happy nowruz
it's great to see you thank you um
as you know
we're hearing that a new iran nuclear
deal is quite close
you have a platform now to say
what you think perhaps should be in it
because as you said there are a lot of
political prisoners uh in iran
and i wondered what you thought the bare
minimum was
in terms of
releases of your fellow prisoners so
that others don't get trapped
um
[Music]
i think it will be a very difficult uh
question to ask for me i'm just gonna
look at it in my own perspective and
that is
um i have been um
in the hands of
the two governments
over the past six years
i did follow the story of jcpoa for the
past six years
very very closely and that is because i
was told many many times that my story
is linked to that which shouldn't have
happened i don't think anybody's life
should be linked to
a global
uh kind of agreement on whatever that is
whether it's nuclear whether it's
environment or whatever every human
being has got the right to be free and i
what really upset upset me all these
years is my life was linked to something
which has got nothing to do with me and
we went through ups and downs of you
know the country is getting very close
to each other and then falling apart and
then there is a war and there's a why do
we have to pay prize for that
what
oh
i think
the remaining dual nationals in iran
their story should not be linked to any
political
slash international agreement human
rights should not be
something that people would look into as
a side
you know kind of a story when they're
doing big deals it has to be on its own
independently a big issue to be solved
so
i was the lucky one who came home there
are so many other people who are still
you know remaining in iran in prison and
i think their story um has to be
separately dealt with and not with any
international agreement
please could you be quite sure because
i'm conscious i'm keeping them a bit
longer than i said i would
um hi i'm amy gibbons from v8 it's
wonderful to see you back um i wanted if
i could ask you a little bit more about
your return to the uk and specifically
some of the first things that you did so
the first place you went the first meal
you had the first tv show you watched if
you did and also you talked about how
you dreamed about doing the school run i
don't suppose you've had a chance to do
that yet you're looking forward to it
and then lastly what do you think will
be the most difficult thing about
adjusting to life back home with your
family i'm not any of those i haven't
got home yet
i was basically living in a suitcase
over the past six years i'm still living
in a suitcase
so my husband has been picking up my
clothes
and
[Music]
i don't know i think it would be
the school run is something that i will
look forward to because i want to get to
know her friends and
the community better
but i also think it will have a lot of
adjustment
um you know getting to know each other
and you know getting to get into each
other's rhythms so we will just take it
very slowly
yes please
hi natalie from hammond high it's a very
local question
um
first of all just so thrilled that
you're back and the whole community is
going to be really thrilled that you're
back marching with richard protesting
and everything
do you you might not know but do you
have plans
to stay in london or are you thinking
we might just kind of get out of london
and start a new life somewhere else no i
think we are planning to stay in london
for the time being
yes please and could i go to you for
sitting down and then i'll just yes okay
we're just it's working to be doing it
row by row so yes
please
hi leslie tomahawknews um
it's obviously been such an awful ordeal
in iran you say that there are so many
others
that had your situation too
is it a little worrying
that the government has been seen to pay
iran in exchange
for people being returned to the united
kingdom
and is there a concern there that it
might encourage more hostage-taking
potentially in the future
there is a moral hazard
um
without doubt um there
you know
a legal debt is not a ransom
um but the guys that took laziness will
be patting themselves on the back and
saying
we did well
let's you know squeeze roxanne's dad
let's try that that's undeniable um it
is a challenge for the government for
the international community generally
to deal with state hostage-taking
that can't be done just with carrots
it can't
it's a balance and it needs to be worked
out and
one of the conversations you've heard me
say
on your shows on others is you know the
government needs to to be brave
and being brave
also means being tough
um that's not a conversation to have
right right now but i think i think in
fairness the foreign affairs committee
review should they choose to do one of
them
giving them a mandate where they would
have actually said they're going to do
one i think that'll be a really valuable
way of exploring it because there are no
easy answers to this and and you know my
view has had a lot of mileage um
everyone agrees and actually you know
how does one deal with tricky policy
questions
it takes a village it's just like
getting less than home
so um i think it's worthwhile having
that conversation in a brave and open
and honest way
and we'll see where where that takes us
thank you okay so i'm very conscious of
time i am keeping them from very long um
gentlemen the man was very eager and
then we there's three more uh
journalists and then that's it please
thank you see you i should see just a
very short question to you
were there any moments of kindness and
from those guarding your cell in prison
and and how do you feel towards those
who kept you captive
uh yes but i'm not going to ask that
question i'm so sorry
sure
and right
lady standing up please
hi lucy fisher from times radio welcome
back nazanin
thanks in part to richard's remarkable
campaigning your face is really well
known in the uk and i wondered if you'd
found so far that you're being
recognized a lot in public and also how
you think you might cope with frankly
your fame
well can i just answer that question
gabriella told me on the phone one day i
was just sitting around that mommy you
do realize that you are very famous and
then it's me and then it's daddy
fine and then i said okay you know it's
not good to be famous because you know
you want to have a normal life and you
know just to have ever and she was like
oh you're not going to be famous forever
maximum a week so we're bracing
ourselves for a week of fame and then
we're just going to have a normal family
very good
and then there was two other journalists
we had who was the next person yes thank
you hi there thank you hannah somerville
from iran wire um my question is also
for nazanin about the friendships that
you developed in prison um just on those
ones left behind is there anyone you can
name that you became particularly close
to in even and if so do you have any
message you'd like to convey to them now
um
yes i i
um i've got
there are people who came out of prison
all the time that i was inside um
that was in iran under house arrest and
then the attack came off i was listening
iran so they
thankfully came out of prison
but the conservationists if i'm
correctly mentioning the name um the
family of of um
of
murad so murad sapider nilofar
um
[Music]
and then there is siamak
the male section
we do not have any contact with them but
we got to see
their families and we get to be very
very close with them so like i said the
meaning of freedom is not going to be
complete until such that they're all
outside and
um at the moment i am with the many
spirits but i am not going to
let the torch be down until the day that
they are
back home to their families thank you
and last question please
hi ella langford from politics home um
ultimately liz trust is the foreign
secretary that got you back why do you
think that she's succeeded where her
predecessors failed and do you feel
confident that should be able to get
other german nationals like roxanne's
father home
i think i would rather not answer any
political questions it is very difficult
for me to
richard
yeah i i mean
it's a good question i think i think a
number of uh less trusted predecessors
were personally vested to try it hard
try different things
i'm really grateful to the current
foreign secretary that she got it over
the line um and you know feeling a
little bit guilty about giving her quite
such a hard time when she took the job
on and we camped on my door um but maybe
that worked um
and and i think yeah i don't know if
it's confidence but absolute hope
that you know she can can get roxanne's
dad back
um and and the others um and i think
um
we should be grateful to her
for having done it
um and and let us hope that that becomes
a pillar of her foreign policy going
forwards that she keeps brits safe and
that she makes sure that you know
whether it's in ukraine or afghanistan
all the other places where people are
vulnerable that that you know it is
something that uk does it looks out for
people
okay can i say thank you um everyone's
been very well behaved and it's it's
worked very smoothly but i'm just going
to ask the panel if there's anything
they want to say that they didn't get
asked about so roxanna is there anything
you'd like to say
are you okay all right richard yeah i in
my long list of thank yous did not
mention any of the legal teams um who
did huge work for us um and some of them
are sitting in this room and have been
very nice about that but so for all the
different legal teams um
you know who did a good job of keeping
the government honest um it's the
important part
of
the conversation is what actually should
the government do in this context
what should it be i think um you know
human rights often gets treated as some
sort of nice cozy rhetoric it's it's
really important our rights
and
yeah just for
keeping us all safe so i we are deeply
indebted for everyone to help that
happen
can i say thank you and could i just say
thank you once again to the speaker's
office who worked really hard sasha
alice and the whole of the speaker's
office really worked hard and my team as
well there's a lot of work that goes on
behind the scenes in an mp's office so
liam and everyone worked really hard and
i would really ask if you wouldn't mind
giving the family their privacy they're
going to go now
roxanne and i are around if you want to
ask any questions
but if richard and nazi will be escorted
out now thank you all very very much oh
gabriella sorry of course i'm gabriella
you're going you're going with mommy and
daddy we're all gonna go now
sorry
i wasn't gonna leave you behind
thank you thank
you a lovely moment there at the end of
that press conference what an
interesting press conference richard
radcliffe there saying uh lovely to feel
that he's going to be retiring from his
role as a campaigner we are whole again
as a family uh nazanin radcliffe
dignified funny sharp as attack um
thankful and grateful to be home
but also uh
really um scathing about
the past six years i was told many times
i will get you home by different foreign
secretaries how many foreign secretaries
does it take what happens now should
have happened six years ago
and asked
how she felt about what had happened she
said i have felt like i'm holding a
black hole in my heart but that she's
left that black hole on the plane that
she is not going to live a life with a
grudge so there nazarene's guy radcliffe
and her husband speaking to the media
for the first time since her release
[Music]